rohark in his last start four and a
third four earned runs throwing to caleb
joseph for the first time tonight
roark has given up four earned runs in
each of his last two starts covering a
total of nine and a third innings
so two down in the top of the first and
now clint frazier
curveball swinging a miss
rohark fans frazier and he rebounds
after that lead-off walk to retire the
next three to face him and here is davey
garcia on the mounds will be his third
start in his young major league career
he's been pretty good so far so runner
at first two out and garcia ready to
deal guerrero a right-hand hitter and
the fastball has popped up
right around the mountain who's going to
catch it it's the shortstop laboratories
right in back of the mound to make the
catch
no runs one hit and one left at the end
of one no score torres who just has not
gotten going is hitting at 225 one home
run and six rbis here comes the 2-2 to
glabor
swung on and it high in the year to left
field that ball is high it is far it is
gone
glabor
and labor day
glebe taurus hits one over the left
center field wall to give the yankees
the lead
like a good glaber torres is there and
the yankees have a one nothing lead blue
jays now have two out of runner back at
first base derrick fisher the batter
joseph on the move again
and fisher gives this one a ride right
center field
and he's hit it out
derrick fisher with a two-run homer and
the blue jays take the lead
we have had some
hitters step up over the last four games
caleb joseph hits a home run in his
first start
danny jansen hits a grand slam
jonathan davis hits a two-run home run
and now derek fisher steps up and
clobbers one over the wall
in right field well we go to the top of
the third and to the top of the order
here's dj who walked his first time
driven out to right field and deep going
back is davis turning looking silly
and the game is tied at two on the solo
home run by le mayo
well le mayhew does not change anything
from yankee stadium or salem field
with that approach
barrel it up and it's up in the air
tonight it looks like the ball is flying
in buffalo
only gave up two hits but they were both
home runs and now he is out of the game
and it's over to ross stripling so now
wade's in scoring position here's luke
voight
there's a base hit through the right
side that is going to score wade easily
so voigt goes against the ship picks up
a single his 30th ruby of the year and
the yankees lead three to two
void at second and hicks at first with
one down and the batter is clint frazier
who has struck out and walked
and he got him
big second out for ross stripling so
first and second two outs here's
glaberturas yankees lead 3-2 we're in
the top of the fifth
hit sharply and inside third and down
the left field line
boyd rounds third he will score
hicks rounds third he's going to score
it's a two run double for torres and the
yankees lead five to two this is the
start of something big but so far
another off speed pitch
he stays on it just enough off the end
of the bat but right down the line
but so far tonight a couple big hits
with runners in scoring position as the
tie turned a little bit
if you're a yankee fan you certainly
hope so
fred gardner will start this at bat 4
new york the 01 pitch is a curveball
lifted in the air right center field
gretchek with a diving grab in left
center field robbing red gardner
fred grinder can't buy a hit in this
series and gretchen takes one away from
it and this ball is slicing away from
grichik off the left-handed hitter's
back he lays out and makes a terrific
catch he's done that a few times here in
buffalo oh davey garcia comes out to
start the seventh inning it'll be vr
joseph and fisher
and the [ __ ] hit on the ground a second
wade from shallow right throws to first
one pitch one out i will always hear
eric kratt saying to me there are two
kinds of people making their major
league debuts one that believe they
belong there and one that think i hope i
do well baby garcia is i belong here
pitch to joseph swung on and popped him
up to shallow right
there's frazier and he makes a catch and
they're two-way
that pitch hit in the air to right
frazier toward right center to make the
catch davey has another one two three he
has been brilliant
and i would say this he's a member of
the rotation
that that i actually can go on a limb
and say he's good he's trying to get a
chance for borucki to face two
left-handed hitters among the three
hitters that he faces tyler wade will be
the batter
joseph coming over for a look
and he got it what a play reaching in to
the blue jays dugout
terrific play by caleb joseph so runners
on the corners one out that brings up
clint frazier 3-2
and there's a base hit through the drawn
in infield
scoring is lemayo
hicks goes to third it's an rbi single
for frasier and the yankees lead six to
two now here's glebe torres now with
runners at second and third
and the pitch is lined off the glove of
panic picked up by vr throws to first in
time
what an odd play scoring is hicks and
the yankees take a 7-2 lead
again a ball just hit on the nose
and a short hops panic but a good
reaction
but the yard takes the out
chapman this is not a safe situation for
him this is the seventh game and there
are two away last line of defense is joe
panic chapman deals the 0-2
strike three ball game over
and the yankees stop the bleeding and
they snap a five-game losing streak